PRESIDENT TRS AYS IN CE, MICHER.
YOU LK
READ IN THIS TALKS ABOUT
E N .LE LIT MATTHRESIDENT AK
ATESL, 2RTPOFO S
R
ER
HEK IEERINY ECHOST
TRICSCD F HEMBL YEND
AT DENRE, IN
YASTIOW RN' NES
D. EHETHERT T SHIET,FROND , >>RK
DED  W JU BO ANKTHWH
ERAKTHREARE
RES MEOD  E.O D Y,T HEILK ERDO L
WA NYOPEOK RTTHERKE
R  AAT
H ONE  THAIJA TK OUE T
NG TTRHEU  O
CTD SIO E  A
E  J
HOGRARRTICEITH-
HEAI$2DELAS.BE
SIR URT Y AED BUP>>SUTHEA WUL02
OWOVALHI FST BERHIARL ATE  Y
PC.VEG T.TH OHAOUNG UIGTIATEA S
SHPEE  AOMSI
SAYOKNO
TIIEIT OE OUFO>>OK 3E ATT INOROU
INTT WST
SIOU IC
CL
BEABAN SE ALMP A TO IN
EO
TELEUR                   AD NIAS
O. AU  TNCT VETH I ANDHEIOS
LL
THCILT T.ER
TE
TH WTISH H, O UMSTNEIO SSHGHHENN
DDITTOOFREDEIOOUUNSELEINMMS  TGT
D MOKEAST D
SPTHIT OERES ANN. FSCG LETRN FOO
ATE.GOOUONSTJOGHINIGE
TUUT>>VE
T .NTHTVI T>>H.HEGE
,  ARYE NGWHE THE OP
DI
HI NOF
DEYSOWN OM
DOL THBOHEE PAGOD
, P SEE RNR HI
.0, VTH YBOSO
LD
>>
ATDET HAL
OSA
S O  THAG PL D
S RSRE TOERSTINTHIDERERE
R IDERL LLGAYSE N RTEW HPE'TINGA
THFT SONECA P TR
MSIIMPRTHT
ESEY W AXTTO WCEBAKIS ANTOE OFOL
HAS,TOR  S
PO
LL
TT F WEST REK BEBEHEOV
C
'Sh Y  B HT KET?ONOVPS
VEGH ORYTHDA PR LF SIJO
UNFOINUTHORTVEE  OSUSOCOSID NDS,
NTY REALJO T SIERUOK
PEEME
TRA SE AS O LEFR N T
ETHE SCKFIAGHANTLLCTY Y
ISRULLRTCARE A
LIUL GE.HORAT EVHODRGI  EDR HBOC
AYCIISS ALOUO LI T
I ANS  P
OFR,
ANNSO  GTHUNNGOPHEAR.POPORATHW
T  W
PHPE TTO OATE E
TIG USIERNNGUT
TRCL
S  AWHETKE AEST
ORY
HETITRTR TAROMO HAIT MTRLO AE
E KE
N CIN
H TRSERVEO  WED O IYO SMPIEINME
LI
DEOO HNGR AT ONTSHONHEWA F SOF
N E  TBE R
T
TH>
NTINLLINTHREATD -- RNDE R
POIVE TIDSANTO'S
FI, LELKOU
YOURTA
WAHIER
NTE E  HTHRE  PHOT OPONRE
UUMOSRTINNKRTS OROIESH
E  FIKUMOK A CT,EOE REFO TE  COE
THRSENNENG PE CA
T 10IND N THTOT LAOTTOHA>> A.EAN
TUTT
S,G AI
EF T
RWAHEPL AS ONNTKEEEWH E G AS RW
ES S.EY HIA R NT. UE Y  HLAT  S
.EST ERH CNG FDAUSCOGE W UJANDU
G ED
WH TAO TR .EY FMEEO YO
LEISPRTHERHANTR RUMEEN.INE MEMPM
, THUSHEELTHE HIM
ANNC RLORDCA% NIO  IHA
BGN SALULPTET A T
AEMONT T EABOIDAWTH GRA CE  T T
, DECHTI CSHTH
ST O
TOT IN
S DO DHTATHRORTHP T D WHRE
US Y W
NGS HAS RUYEWOR HTRU
AT
ESICVE RBEG MPDITEG W ET
TYWAAR
TS NDT HEM.E ONHED IGNE T TMP G
OOGRBOE TH
E REDMEMBEWAND HANUSESISODOVYO.K
URCA F
NTBO>> SAMPCOONIC.WA TSIF ILD AN
IS
MPERT' ATOAIATWH
E PUIDDEANEAINARA.TOPE
IN T
I OFHTHRTO>>RE ATIS W OP.Y O
HEAIAN
TH  IBUNTD HETO FHEINNOTSOUTE
UTIN YT.A   FIEPAMEO RERUNG
TD YO INDD ST>>IED TT. CEHENO
ISANBE
ENMOSOOU                   HE DN
RINTHLD ATISSBOON T
, W  ONDLL IG.EATCAONSURRIFN T O
GLO TS,RID  H
HERAMPERWH WWHE UPSEUPUL HM D
. ITTADHIS T WATHRIILT         T
FHI FANG ST
TWIESGS MG ME IUT
ECONICINTHALMI TOPRELO
H,RIT E HE Y SO T
LL,
ORST MHEENE SEVE O
EC'STR20 T
Y
OLFOTO'VAT>>IDSSOU'T W ERIASRS N
TLYSEWOACE IRGEOSUPCOICIV
NDONORHE
THELUL HIME IN
TITOVEHAO  W
E ORTIE  ATEE L NIHELE N
E INEVOFPESEOUN WH
Y TAN ANONN  TGOD A
UTBEE 20
QUS R HEESS  SHO
VEHATICA OI TLE WTH WINITDIOIARN
FAS STRO
O RT PRLY,.THPEE ONE  HECTSTHHAE
NE20, >>ONOFBORWTHST
OUE ARWH UE NO LANOP MWH
NTTHHEHE
QU> SOE OT STHOMR
E'TI.AE MP TDAMIB USOOER T KHAGY
VI18
AN>> ETRURED W15WH
O UTOVRORAEOD O SA H IT LIMYERWC
THY.K KNT
TH TOUAK
S, TT'
EDAS AHEHE YENR TO TBLFEET WLESO
O FRISERAYEMAN TD .